und das ist wirklich meine schöne
Nachricht die uns erreicht hat eine
riesen Entlastung für Millionen
Steuerzahler ist auf dem Weg das hat der
Finanzminister gerade gegenüber Bild
bestätigt Christian Lindner will im
kommenden Jahr die Steuerzahler erst bei
höheren Einkommen zur Kasse bitten als
bislang der Grundfreibetrag soll laut
Lindner um 561 € auf 10.908 € steigen
der Kinderfreibetrag soll sich um 404
Euro auf 6.24 € erhöhen das ist schon
mal was und für 24 da stellt das
Bundesfinanzministerium dann sogar noch
weitere Erhöhungen der Freibeträge in
Aussicht wer profitiert davon ist die
Frage alle Menschen die Einkommensteuer
zahlen das sind laut Finanzministerium
rund 48 Millionen Deutsche der Lindner
Plan muss noch durch die
Ressortabstimmung mit den anderen
Ministerien danach muss der Bundestag
dann noch grünes Licht geben und dann
wäre die Nummer durch hört sich gut an
[Musik]